We are in November. And do you remember
like 2 months ago they were looking at
this 3I Atlas saying hostile aliens are
going to be here in November. Today is
November 4th. And I'm waiting on those
aliens. The government is shut down
right now. And so NASA being a
government-funded agency, they're not
really releasing pictures that they
have. And there's all kinds of muddying
of the water, conspiracy theories, and
misinformation, disinformation. But
I'm going to I'm going to point out some
things that are going on right now.
Because the media likes to promote one
side and not the other. And mock and
ridicule one side and praise the other
side. So why does the press mock the
concept of fallen angels but roll out
the red carpet for it might be a craft
in disguise. Mm. Marjorie Taylor Greene
just went on a talk show and she said
that she believes
aliens are fallen angels. Avi Loeb, this
guy has been on the news, mainstream
media news, like crazy. He's saying that
there is something strange about this
comet. So you know, I'm talking to
people who are really into mainstream
media. And they're saying, "No, you
know, this they've already debunked this
thing. It's It's just a comet. They're
watching it. It's going behind the the
sun." I got a lot of questions about
some of that anyway. They tell us that
the sun is a thousand times bigger than
the earth. It's 93 million miles away.
And yet they're looking at a comet the
size of Manhattan and following that
thing behind the sun. I got questions. I
don't believe that they're seeing stuff,
but that's just my own personal opinion.
Uh they seem to have a lot of
information about this comet. They can
tell what's what the core of it is made
out of. I got questions about that kind
of thing. But either way,
there's some there's some people that
are saying they debunked it. It's just a
comet. It's just going. And yet this guy
right here, Avi Loeb, keeps getting the
mainstream media platform. And what's he
keep saying?
There's something strange about this.
It's moving in ways that gravity
shouldn't allow if it's just a comet.
It's changing colors. It's got I've even
read that there are geysers
uh simultaneously
igniting on this thing all over. And
they're say people are saying this is
exhaust. When you look up Marjorie
Taylor Greene and and look up what the
media right now is saying about her,
they are mocking and ridiculing her for
sharing her ideas that these things
could be demons. Why not? Hey, this is
2025. We're like open-minded, right? We
don't You're not allowed to like mock
people's beliefs. If you believe it,
then it must be true, right? If you
believe you're uh a woman and you're
actually a male, then you have to agree
with that. You you can't disagree
because that's hate speech, right? But
this lady shares that according to her
personal belief system, she believes
these things are fallen angels. And yet
they mock and ridicule her.
And you see here's more articles where
they're saying, you know, "Oh, she
thinks they're fallen angels." Um we're
going to look at that last article, too,
that says The Times. It says, "In an age
of demons, we must fight to enlighten."
We're going to look at that. But I want
to just show you the bias, the the
mainstream narrative bias when you look
up these topics on Google. And she was
on Bill Maher's show. And this is what
she said. She shared her belief about
that she thinks these things are aliens.
Now, I'm going to I'm going to show you
this straight from YouTube because I
want you to see that this got 1.1
million views in 3 days. All right?
These are the platforms that people are
watching. They're not watching these
other things that are saying, "Oh, it's
just a comet or whatever." This
interview took a turn because in the
beginning he's he's announcing
the director for some new documentary
coming out called uh something about
disclosure. And they're plotting him and
praising him. "Oh, he's so brave to be
talking about the subject, you know, the
government's hiding this stuff and we
need to the people need to know, right?"
That's what they're saying.
And then he goes on and and says this.
Listen to this.
You know what I find scary? The part
about the the people at the Pentagon who
say it's demons.
Tell him tell him that story. Tell him
about the demons. It's Halloween. Yes.
Tell him about the demons at the
What is that?
Okay, you you already hear like the
people laughing, right? He the way he's
presenting he's like, "Oh, yeah. Tell
them about the people that believe in
demons, right?"
And the whole crowd is laughing. Listen.
So uh
so
in in the film, one of the senior
intelligence officials
named Jay Stratton, he was the director
of Air and Space Warfare at the Defense
Intelligence Agency. And then he ran the
US government's UAP Task Force.
He tells a story about how he was trying
to run this issue up the flagpole and
bring attention to it. At the Pentagon.
At the Pentagon.
In a serious office space. And
uh
his superiors told him that they thought
these things were demons and that he was
doing the devil's work by looking into
it. And on camera in the film, he says,
"I can't believe these words were coming
out of their mouths." He's like, "I'm
briefing them on an advanced aerospace
vehicle that's absolutely there. It's
been spotted by trained observers like
our Navy fighter pilot." So he's like
saying, "I can't believe these words are
coming out of their mouth because these
things are real. We We look at them on
instruments, on radar, and all this
stuff." So they're thinking that because
these people said they think it's
demonic that they're not physically
there, I guess. Demons are real. I mean,
if you believe in the spirit world, if
you believe the Bible, demons are very
real. And they appear to humans and have
throughout all history. Think about the
Garden of Eden, right? Eve actually
talked to a physical snake in the
garden. That's just one example. But
they're they're mocking this idea that
these things could be demonic. pilots in
their $80 million airplanes that we
trust them with, right? It's been
spotted on data collection systems like
satellite and radar. And this guy's
telling me it's a demon. It's insane.
And Insane. And he's like, "My mind was
blown and this is something I'm dealing
with inside of the government." It's
Halloween. Let me just ask the final
questions for the panel. Do you think
demons and the devil are real?
Absolutely. I'm a Bible-believing
Christian. I definitely and I believe
those could be fallen angels. All these
things could be real.
>> Fallen angels? Yeah. Fallen
>> The aliens are fallen angels? That's
possible. I think that's what they could
be. That's what makes sense in my my
worldview.
Michael? No.
Sorry.
And that's why we came here to disagree
but still
appreciate each other for having the
conversation. Happy Halloween. Thank you
very much. It was like three to one plus
the audience
all mocking and ridiculing the idea that
aliens could be demons.
All right. So this is what the
mainstream media is pushing, right?
They're They're making you believe
they're programming you with programs
that the idea of demons in disguise,
disguising themselves as aliens to
deceive the entire world like the Bible
actually says,
is ridiculous. "It's just insane," the
guy said, "to think that."
Uh I think that's very interesting
because the media is a powerful powerful
tool. It brainwashes people, literally.
When you look up who is Marjorie Taylor
Greene,
you're going to see, you know, she's 51
years old. She
uh
she's a US representative.
But then you scroll a little bit further
and you see right here it says is an
American far-right
politician, businesswoman, and
conspiracy theorist. Now, why would they
say that? Why Why are they going to
label her a conspiracy theorist? Why?
Because she actually thinks outside the
box. She actually thinks outside the
mainstream narrative. Now, I I know
nothing about this woman. I'm not
promoting her. Don't get it twisted. If
you guys know me at all, you know that I
think that all politicians are all
puppets. Satan's the god of this world.
We We wrestle not against flesh and
blood, but against principalities,
against the powers of the rulers of the
darkness of this age. Satan is at the
top. It doesn't matter who you vote for.
Your votes don't count. Trump's a
puppet. Biden's a puppet. They're all
puppets, two wings of the same bird,
left wing, right wing. But what I'm
getting at is this is brainwashing
propaganda.
This woman believes some things, at
least her character that she plays
believes some things that I believe.
But they label her a conspiracy theorist
because that word comes with a stigma to
it. There's nothing wrong with the word
conspiracy. We know that conspiracies
are real. They've existed for all of
time that you know, you can't trust
kings and rulers and Hitler or Stalin or
Pharaoh. It goes all the way back to the
beginning of time. You cannot trust the
leaders of this world because they are
conspiracist. They are conspiring behind
the scenes. And the word theory, nothing
wrong with theory. That's like the next
step right before a scientific fact,
right?
But you put the words together and
suddenly you get this stigmatized word,
a label, conspiracy theorist. So you
look her up. What I'm getting at is you
look her up, this lady who's actually
thinking outside the box,
voicing opinions that aren't the normal
mainstream narrative, right? Conspiracy
theorist.
Well, yeah. Just look at this. The
Guardian talked about this.
They said uh
Marjorie Taylor Greene tells Bill Maher
she believes extraterrestrials are
demons. Georgia Republican lawmaker also
claims she didn't know Rothschild's
family or of her space laser theory was
Jewish. So, she said something back in
2018.
Something that I actually believe. She
said that the California wildfires, she
thought, were caused by lasers
from from space, from satellites or
something.
She thinks that lasers start those
fires. Now they're bringing up that
conspiracy theory, bringing it back to
the surface to make her look nuts,
right? Cuz cuz they know that this is
not the mainstream belief from people.
So, they're like, "Oh,
aliens are demons, woo, and there's
Jewish space lasers out there." You
know, it says right here, "Republican US
House member Marjorie Taylor Greene has
said that she believes in demons,
surmising that they might be aliens who
fell from heaven, and claims to be
unaware that key figures
in the anti-Semitic space lasers
conspiracy she floated were Jewish."
She didn't say anything about Jewish
people whatsoever.
We're going to look at that post later.
She made a post on X in 2018 about It
was a lengthy post, and she was making
some valid points, and she's saying
she's questioning questioning the
mainstream narrative. These fires don't
look natural. I believe that there is a
conspiracy going on. I believe they were
started by lasers. She never mentioned
anything about Jewish laser beams or
anything like that, but they're labeling
her anti-Semitic. That's another hate
speech. You know, there's all these
protected sects out there, right?
There's the LGBT movement. You're not
allowed to say anything against them.
That's a hate speech. You're not allowed
to say anything against this minority of
people because it's anti-Semitic. So,
automatically, if you say anything about
this group of people, you're wrong.
You're the one that's racist. You're
racist.
And when you look up the the guy who
directed this
UFO documentary, The Age of Disclosure,
this is what you see. Instead of seeing,
"Oh, conspiracy theorist" and all this,
right? Because he's actually saying,
"The public needs to know the truth. The
government's hiding that aliens are
real, that UFOs are real. We demand that
you tell us the truth." And he's not
labeled a conspiracy theorist. No, it's
Dan Dan Farrah is an American producer,
director, and manager known for
producing his blockbuster film Ready
Player One and directing the documentary
The Age of Disclosure. Wait, it doesn't
say, "Directed the conspiracy theorist
documentary The Age of Disclosure." No,
it's just it's proclaiming it like it's
something great. So, I just want you to
see the the comparison, right? You got
conspiracy theorist and acclaimed film
director who who's directing this movie
documentary The Age of Disclosure. Oh,
he's so great.
When you look up 3I Atlas, this is what
the top news is. Notice I screenshotted
this from Google. Top news
New York Post. Manhattan-sized
interstellar object 3I Atlas
accelerates and turns bluer. Some think
3I Atlas is a comet. This scientist says
it may be a UFO. The Times.
The The Economic Times. 3I Atlas shows
signs of alien engine and
non-gravitational acceleration.
Oh, South Florida media. Interstellar
object 3I Atlas exhibits unexpected
non-gravitational acceleration.
Mysterious 3I Atlas interstellar object
continues to do weird stuff. So, the
main the Right now, what they're pushing
from the mainstream media
is this thing is not normal.
That the government's hiding something
from you. NASA's hiding something from
you. See, I've been saying this for
years. I've been saying that I predict
that the military, the the the rulers,
the elites, the powers that be
are going to release leaks. They're
going to release whistleblowers on
mainstream media news. Let me tell you
something. Whistleblowers don't get to
be on mainstream media news. Those ideas
don't coexist.
If you are a whistleblower, you don't
get on the major platform. You're in
hiding. You're You're trying to find
refuge somewhere because your life is
being threatened. You don't get to be on
the controlled media.
But that's what they do. So, they're
they're convincing people that they're
tracking some I I got duped into this as
a teenager.
As a teenager and in my early 20s I
believed that I was tracking that the
government was hiding something from us.
I saw the ancient or I saw the alien
autopsy video, and I was like, "They're
trying to hide" You know, I I was
tracking this stuff and saying, "I want
to know the truth, and and aliens are
real, and they're trying to say it's
swamp gas and weather balloons and all
this stuff."
And what I didn't know was I was being
duped.
William Cooper talked about this.
William Behold a Pale Horse. He worked
in the government. He saw UFOs with his
own eyes flying around and doing
impossible maneuvers, and he thought,
"I'm going to tell everyone. I'm going
to break this thing wide open." Wrote a
book and was saying how aliens are real
and the military's hiding them. And then
he wait He thought, "Wait a minute.
What if this is What if this is exactly
what they wanted me to do? They were
hoping that I would become a
whistleblower and leak out things to the
public so that the public would hear the
the false
as the truth. It It's so deep, I don't
even know how to like put it into words
for you guys. But when you keep looking
this stuff up,
you're going to see 3I Atlas
and NASA hiding evidence.
Why Avi Loeb Congress Congress are
demanding interstellar data to be
released. 3I Atlas, the comet from
another world, continues to baffle.
Nine reasons this scientist is
suspicious. The object screaming past
the sun is a city-sized alien
spacecraft.
And here you'll see mainstream media
sources like NBC News, NewsNation.
They're all interviewing this guy, you
know, on the edge of their seat like,
"Tell us, Harvard professor, please tell
us why you think that this is really an
alien ship in disguise." Let me play it
from YouTube so you can see
that these are the ones that are getting
in 21 hours
about a million and a half views. If I
were to refresh this, it would probably
be a million and a half views
in less than a full day in 21 hours.
And what is he saying? I'll I'll play
part of it just so you can get the
general idea. Actually, I'm going to
show you a clip that shows some of the
things he's saying, and side by side
with some predictive programming,
actually. If you guys are on the same
mindset as me,
then you understand that Hollywood puts
this stuff out in predictive
programming.
It's It's Satan's prophecies. Basically,
God does everything, and he and he
reveals it through his prophets. He
gives prophecy through the Bible, and
Satan counterfeits everything God does.
So,
you know, we have God's word. It's a
book, ancient scrolls, and Satan says,
"You know what? I'm going to captivate
the minds of humanity with glowing
screens and million-dollar budgets and,
you know, excitement and all these
things, and I'm going to tell them my
side of the story. I'm going to tell
them my prophecies. I'm going to make
God look like a villain. I'm going to
make myself look like a hero, and I'm
going to give that same story over and
over and over, and literally program the
masses with my Hollywood spell that
broadcasts
over humanity." Here is the lady
announces. You'll You'll get the gist of
what this guy believes from what she's
saying here.
to like a side order of conspiracy
theory with their servings of UFOs. He
claims, Avi Loeb does, that NASA is
keeping critical evidence about 3I Atlas
away from public view. Professor And And
he is hailed as some hero, right?
Because he wants the public to know the
truth.
Check this out. Here's predictive
programming. This is from a show called
a TV series called Salvation,
ironically. Called Salvation, okay?
Man, all this stuff is so deep.
I'm going to get into what where I think
all this is going, but this is
put on a YouTube channel called God's
Roadmap to the End. I never heard of it
till today when somebody sent me this.
And this is
was very good catch. Check this out.
Project Atlas. Atlas? I've never heard
of it.
>> Atlas.
Grace,
don't say that word
to anybody, ever.
The name is simply that it refers to the
third interstellar object, object from
outside the solar system that is
visiting us. And Atlas is a telescope
half a meter in diameter in Chile that
discovered it on July 1st, 2025.
Professor Cropped is Liam.
I got a hit. You got a hit? Yeah. I'm
going to go back to bed, and if you're
lucky, I won't remember this in the
morning.
>> They asked me to wake up at 3:00 a.m. to
speak with them, and I actually woke up
at the 2:00 a.m.
>> There's a significant perturbation.
Really? I've been running continuous
simulations, and there's something there
that was not there 3 months ago.
>> You know, a slight miscalculation could
taint the results. Why don't you give me
the data? I'll take a look.
>> Yes, it's it's already uploaded to your
server.
>> So, I was up, and then I noticed I sent
me an email and said
there is a new interstellar object.
Three months ago
through the safeguard survey system that
catalogs near Earth objects, NASA
astronomer Dr. Edward Acosta discovered
an asteroid 7 km wide out near Jupiter,
large enough to cause an
extinction-level event. Professor Loeb
suspects that it might actually be alien
technology scoping us out. And for those
who like a side order of conspiracy
theory with their servings of UFOs, he
claims, Avi Loeb does, that NASA is
keeping critical evidence about 3I Atlas
away from public view. Project Atlas
grace, it was a weapon wielded by
America using
my guidance system. So Katia was right.
Atlas is a weapons program.
>> Yes, except the weapon
was an asteroid.
What was found, you know, and that's by
multiple teams. There are three papers
on that.
We found
nickel, a lot of nickel. I have new
information.
It can't wait.
Initially, we thought Samson was made of
silicates, porous rock, but the
collision this evening suggests it has
an iron core, much denser than what we
thought. The only place where we found
before much more nickel than iron is in
alloys that we produce industrially. For
example,
uh for aerospace applications. So,
maybe the skin of this object is is
industrially produced.
>> None of your ideas will work because the
asteroid has an iron core.
And as of a few hours ago, the first
hint for a non-gravitational
acceleration, meaning something is
affecting its trajectory beyond gravity.
Liam, can't you see?
Our math was correct. The asteroid did
move. But the trajectory
it hasn't changed. Exactly.
Because it's a hummingbird.
It moved.
And then it moved back.
So,
the question was,
you know, is it something other than a
natural object? It followed the
trajectory
that was aligned with the planets around
the sun. So, perhaps it's on some
reconnaissance mission.
It's not an asteroid.
Why?
Perhaps for a reason, you know, if it's
a technological object, that's the best
time for it to do a maneuver when it's
closest to the sun to take advantage of
the sun's gravity. That's what we do
with our own spacecraft. Uh and so, the
question is, will it appear on a
different path after passing close to
the sun? And of course, if that happens,
you know, the stock market may crash cuz
it would mean that, you know, we have
some risk involved.
It's not an asteroid.
What the hell is it?
[Applause]
Whatever it is.
It's here.
It's here, guys.
November Atlas
is is about to get crazier. Look, this
is this is what they want you to
believe. I I just I have to tell you
that. I have to like drill this into
your minds if you if you already don't
know.
They want you to believe in aliens.
It It's all It's all misdirection. It's
all uh psychological warfare, you know,
it's
reverse psychology. You know, for years
they told us they were No, it's not
really aliens. It's not really UFOs.
It's swamp gas and weather balloons. And
now suddenly the media's like, "Oh, we
got a whistleblower. Uh-oh, here's a
here's a Navy guy. He said the aliens
are real. What about this guy? Oh, wait,
NASA's trying to hide something. Wait,
the government shut down. Oh Come on
now, we want to know the truth."
They This is order out of chaos. They
are manufacturing the chaos
so that we will fall in for for the
order because when you put fear in
people that there're aliens coming, that
there's asteroids coming, that there's
riots, that there's race wars, that
there's all these things going on,
natural disasters everywhere,
people will cry out for a savior.
And Satan can come upon the scenes as a
supernatural being doing lying signs and
wonders, and miracle-working demons will
deceive the entire world into believing
that this is Christ. He has come.
Like the the Jews, they rejected Christ.
They're waiting for their Messiah, so
they're they're already set up for it.
The New Agers, they're waiting for
Maitreya and all this stuff. Raelians,
they're waiting for Jesus to come back
on a spaceship. Everybody is set up to
receive Christ coming and and setting
foot on Earth, even though when you read
prophecy, that's not what it says. It
says he's coming like lightning flashes
from the east to the west, and we're
going to be caught up to meet the Lord
in the air, not him coming down here for
miracles. Jesus said if they say I'm in
the secret chambers, don't go. If they
say I'm in the desert, don't go. I'm not
there. That's not me.
But yet, that's exactly what's going to
happen. And I've been saying this, and I
don't know, you know, I I hate to say
like mark my word or something, but
this hit me one day, and I really
believe that this is going to happen
that Trump is being set up as this
Antichrist decoy. That he's fulfilling
all the prophecies of the Antichrist,
and all these Trumpers are going to now
say, "Wait a minute, I was duped. I fell
for this wicked man. I fell for the
Antichrist." And Satan will appear as an
angel of light,
destroy Trump, and whether it's for real
or not,
and then people will say, "Well, this
has to be Christ because he just killed
the Antichrist. The Antichrist came, now
Christ is here." Satan knows that
Christians are waiting for the
Antichrist to appear first.
And so, my belief is
that Satan is setting up the stage right
now
to make make Trump look like an
Antichrist. Like he's They're calling
him Cyrus. They're calling him
Constantine. He's building this Arch of
Baal, like rolling out AI surveillance,
Stargate technology, and all these
things.
Everything that people didn't think
Trump was going to do, now he's doing,
right? And so now they're all falling
for it and saying, "Oh, we you know,
we've been deceived. We fell for the
Antichrist." So, there has been soft
disclosure this whole time. Like
everybody keeps waiting for, you know,
when when's the the aliens going to come
on the White House and they shake hands
and and it's this big disclosure.
They've been giving us disclosure this
whole time. December 2019, the US
created a space force. Why in the world
would we have a military branch pointing
weapons towards the heavens?
Right? Because they're telling us, "Oh,
an asteroid's coming so close to Earth.
Oh, we're seeing things in the sky,
right?" December 2019,
we created a space force right during
that time, right? COVID happened.
And in the In 2020, there was a COVID
relief legislation bill that had over a
5,000 pages in it. And in that bill, for
some reason about COVID and relief
legislation and all this stuff, it said,
"We demand to know everything you know
about UFOs."
What do UFOs have to do with COVID? I
don't know, but it was all to set the
stage, right? During 2020, they started
saying, "Yeah, we we see things every
day. We don't know what they are." Every
day. We don't know if they're It's not
our technology. It's not their
technology. So, it has to be something
else. This is what Lou Elizondo and all
these guys were saying. They were
getting all this mainstream media
attention saying, "We don't know what
they are, but they're not they're not
from here cuz it's not our technology or
their technology." Then in 2023,
they they said a little bit more. It's
always a a little more, right? Because
now we went from, "Oh yeah, we see some
strange things" to
actually we actually communicate with
non-human intelligences. This is what
they're saying in US congressional
hearings.
And
like the judges or whoever are up there
are saying, "Well, are they alien?" And
they're saying, "Well, we don't like to
say alien exactly. We don't know We
don't know what they are. They could be
interdimensional."
They're telling us we communicate with
interdimensional beings.
The military is telling us this.
That is
highly prophetic, and we will get into
that. We will look at those verses.
Highly prophetic that the militaries of
the world are going to be communicating
with interdimensional beings
who are going to prepare them for a
soon-to-come war. When this lady said
that she thinks that aliens are fallen
angels, and
you know, she got mocked and ridiculed
and all that stuff. This is not a joke.
This is not some tinfoil hat conspiracy
theory. When you read the Bible, there
are false gods mentioned by name. Baal.
Baal was mentioned many times in the
Bible by name.
And where does he come from? Well, he
represents the sun.
He He comes from Jupiter and Venus. He
represents these
heavenly bodies in the sky.
An alien, if you will.
This godlike being
came from another planet or a star or
solar system or somewhere in the
heavens. There was another one,
Astaroth, Astarte, Ishtar. The word
Astarte literally is where we get the
word star from.
And she represents Venus and the sun and
the moon. So, here's another godlike
supernatural godlike creature, a woman
with wings and owl feet,
who came from another planet.
The Bible talks about aliens, literally.
But they're not aliens in the sense that
we've been programmed to believe.
They're demons in disguise and the Bible
will tell you that clearly.
Moloch or Molech
represents the sun deity because Molech
and Baal were like one in the same. It
says Molech is sometimes linked to the
sun god Baal, which would connect him to
the sun. And if you believe
you know, the solar system that we've
been taught, then the sun is just one
little star in a mix of unlimited stars
out there, right?
Tammuz represents Venus.
So, here's another alien that the Bible
talks about, Tammuz.
Artemis
represents the moon and the night stars
in the sky.
So,
we can look at the Bible alone and
history and see that humanity has had
communication with
aliens, right? All throughout history.
And this one is not in the Bible, but
you can look at history and see etchings
and writings and everything about the
Anunnaki, a pantheon of gods
that were a pantheon of deities often
described as the children of the sky and
earth. Prominent members including Anu,
Enlil, Enlil, and Enki.
Shared belief system, ancient Sumerians,
Akkadians, the Babylonians believed in
the Anunnaki and their role in creation
and controlling destiny. Now, I think
that's interesting because the Bible
talks about the dragon, that serpent of
old is going to deceive the entire
world. How is he going to deceive every
single belief system, every single
different religion, even non-religious
people like atheists? How is Satan going
to deceive the entire world including
atheist?
Well, atheists say, you know, I believe
it when I see it. God, show yourself to
me. Well,
God doesn't have to prove himself. He
doesn't have to show himself to anyone.
He believes in free will and no atheist
is going to shake their puny little fist
at God if he cracked the sky open and
revealed himself. So, for God to reveal
himself on that kind of level literally
eliminates free will because you become
an ant in the sight of some cosmic
giant.
But guess who will appear?
Satan
disguised as visitants from other
worlds.
And it's happened already all through
history. We literally seen it in the
Bible. We're seeing it in the history
that ancient people have had
communication with beings from the
stars. The heathens worshipped these
beings from the stars.
And Deuteronomy 32:17
says about these beings,
they sacrificed unto devils, not to God,
to gods whom they knew not, to new gods
that came newly up whom your fathers
feared not. So,
God's saying that these little g gods
that they worshipped and sacrificed to,
they were devils. They weren't gods.
They're not gods. They're demons in
disguise. What I was getting at is
atheists do believe that aliens are
real.
Actually, if you watch the movie the
documentary Thinking Not Allowed or
something like that, he was interviewing
Richard Dawkins
and he said, "What do you think about
God?" And and he says, "Oh, God's a
infanticidal, genocidal, homophobic, all
these things." He's just tearing into
God.
And then
the interviewer says,
"Well, where do you think we came from?"
And he said, "Um, I don't know. We could
have been seeded here by aliens." So, a
militant atheist is not opposed to the
idea that we could have been seeded here
by aliens. Well, who created the aliens?
Well, we just saw that the Anunnaki,
they the people believe that the
Anunnaki created us, that they're our
creators, they're our gods, right? But
these gods are devils as the Bible says.
Psalm 106: 37 says, "Yea, they
sacrificed their sons and daughters unto
devils."
These people thought they were
sacrificing to gods like Molech and
Baal, but no, they were devils.
Leviticus 17:7 says, "And they shall no
more offer their sacrifices unto devils
after whom they have gone a whoring.
This shall be a statute forever unto
them throughout their generations." New
Testament, 1 Corinthians 10:20, "But I
say that the things which the Gentiles
sacrifice, they sacrifice to devils and
not to God.
And I would not that they should have
fellowship with devils."
So, God is
trying to keep us from fellowshipping
with devils.
Why? Not because he's
trying to keep us from secret knowledge
or wisdom or anything like that, right?
But that's what Satan
deceived Eve with.
He said, "If you eat this fruit that
God's keeping you from, you'll be wise
like him, knowing good and evil. You'll
become like God."
And so, Eve fell for the trick. She got
deceived. She ate the fruit thinking
that she would become like God.
And and this has happened all through
history that
fallen angels in disguise have given men
technology and
taught them how to do root cutting and
hallucinogenic drugs and
weapons and all of this.
All through history this has been
happening.
And that is not what God wants us to do.
He says, "I do not I do not want you to
have fellowship with devils." And what
is the military literally telling us
that is happening at US congressional
hearings?
They're saying, "Oh, we communicate with
non-human intelligences."
They're telling us this
publicly on television that they
communicate with devils.
Because the Bible says, "If you're
communicating with interdimensional
beings, they're devils."
Devils in disguise.
This is nothing new. This is exactly
what happened to Eve. She was approached
by a reptilian creature, an intelligent,
beautiful, speaking reptilian creature
that fell from the heavens
and was promising her knowledge and
wisdom. And I believe that's exactly
what's going to happen in these last
days, that the militaries of the world
are communicating with these
interdimensional beings, non-human
intelligences, and they're learning how
to make anti-gravity craft. They're um
you know, they're getting wisdom and
knowledge from these higher level
beings, these higher evolved beings.
So, what I predict
is that soon and very soon
the government is going to say, "Look,
we didn't want to cause chaos. We didn't
want to cause fear and panic.
But we can't hide it anymore. We have to
let you know that aliens are here and
they've been here for thousands of years
living among us and they've never harmed
us. Actually, they've actually helped us
throughout the years. They've disarmed
nukes. They've done this and that. They
have helped us along the way because oh,
if anybody's ever had a a miraculous
healing from an angel or something like
that, you can guarantee they're going to
say that was the aliens doing that.
And they're going to say, "Look, the
aliens have been among us this whole
time and they've never hurt us. In fact,
they're here to help us because there is
an evil alien invader coming to Earth
and if unless we side with them,
humanity is going to become extinct."
And what you're going to have is humans
siding with demons in disguise
in a fight against Christ. If you think
that sounds
like some sci-fi movie, it does,
but it's actually prophecy. In
Revelation 16:13 and 14, it says, "I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs come
out of the mouth of the dragon, out of
the mouth of the beast, out of the mouth
of the false prophet, for they are the
spirits of devils." So, these unclean
spirits that are like frogs are actually
the spirits of devils. And what are they
doing? They're working miracles. They're
flying around in ships and defying
physics and doing things that we've
never seen them do. Actually, Chris
Bledsoe said that he was healed of his
Crohn's disease by aliens. And so, now
he believes that they are good angels
just because they healed him. But what
does the Bible say? They're
miracle-working devils.
Which go forth to the kings of the earth
and of the whole world.
Yeah, the military who's on US
congressional hearings right now, these
devils are rounding up the kings of the
whole world to gather them to the battle
of the great day of God Almighty.
This is the time we're living in right
now. This is no longer far future
prophecy. We are living in this prophecy
right now.
Where the military is openly admitting,
"We communicate with these beings."
And look at this. This came up when I
looked up this lady, what she said and
how she was mocked and ridiculed for
thinking that these are demons.
And this article came up in The Times
written by this James Marriott person.
And it says, "In an age of demons, we
must fight to enlighten.
The ease with which the world has
slipped back into superstition shows how
badly we need the crusading spirit of
the 18th century enlightenment
thinkers."
This was written November 3rd, my
birthday, yesterday.
This was written
yesterday.
It's hard to read the news without
lapsing into a misty-eyed re- reverie
on the lost virtues of the
enlightenment. Last week, the US
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene suggested that
UFOs are probably demons or fallen
angels expelled from heaven for their
sins. That, she said, is what makes
sense in my worldview.
Well, who can argue with such logic?
This person is being so sarcastic and
saying, "Your archaic beliefs that
aliens are actually demons are just
that, these archaic beliefs, and shame
on you for even thinking that way.
You're a caveman. Get out of our society
because we live in a society that
embraces demons, I mean aliens."
See, if you
speak out against these beings,
you will be looked at as a hater.
You will be looked at as a bigot,
as some archaic caveman, because of this
right here. This is the type of stuff
that got us into that mindset. Is it
wrong to to not address someone as what
they identify themselves as? And the
answer says, "It's not only
disrespectful, it's hateful behavior on
the part of the person doing it and
harmful to the transgender person being
harassed." So, this is the context of
transgender, but look,
where does that Where do you draw that
line when it comes to what you identify
as, right? Because
maybe you identify as a dog, maybe you
identify as a a cat, or maybe you
identify as an alien like this person
after having some fingers and his ears
removed, the black alien abandons his
body modification project. So,
this guy identifies as an alien.
Now, if we live in a world where you
must conform to people's identity,
then what do you think is going to
happen when
beings from another world come? You're
calling them a demon.
They're going to say, "You're a hater.
We need to embrace these people. We need
to have open borders for everything. You
know, universal open borders. Let all
the aliens come in." Right? Thank you
for the thumbs down, guys.
Every little bit helps. Thumbs up,
thumbs down.
Let me see. We got two thumbs down.
Thanks, guys.
Now, Bill Bill Ma- Maher Bill Maher
could barely believe
Marjorie Taylor Greene's insane Jewish
space laser thing is real. I think Oh,
he said, "I think aliens probed her and
her brains fell out."
So, here's where he's responding to her
post, which I'm going to read now.
She made this post on X and it's long.
I'm not going to read all of it, but she
said, um "There's 70 people confirmed
dead, uh a thousand missing people in
the California fires and it's tragic and
she's, you know, she's praying for the
people, but she says right here, she
says, "All right, it's a lot. I'm not
going to read all this, but
basically in here, she does talk about
um lasers.
And she says,
"I really hope they have very good aim
beaming the sun's power down to Earth,
but what do I know? I just like to read
a lot."
Now, if you think this is crazy, check
out DARPA Popular Mechanics. DARPA,
"The space laser wars have begun and
America wants to be first to develop a
high-powered weapons." Now, this this
article came out
this month or this year, 2025.
They're saying that they want to do it.
Um here's
Space Force, actually,
with their video about lasers.
And
here's USA Today saying that an image
captures US Navy testing its new laser
weapons. What to know about Helios. They
always name everything they do after
pagan gods. That's not a coincidence. It
lines up with exactly this study right
here.
This was also this year.
But when you really look into
declassified
things, congress.gov talks about
Department of Defense directed energy
weapons background and issues for
Congress.
This was 2024 that it got declassified
and
you know, shown to the public and here
it's talking about Helios.
Here's
uh
gao.gov
science and tech spotlight.
This was 2023
and they're talking about their laser
weapon systems.
What about this one?
ndia.org
is a whole manual on directed energy
weapon supply chains.
They're creating these things, January
2024.
This is not conspiracy theory. Don't let
people label you that way just because
you actually question the narrative.
Look at this. It said, "Cleared for open
publication, August 18th, 2023." That's
when it became public. "The need for
speed, the case for continued
development of hypersonic and directed
energy weapons."
Now, I want to show you a clip from a
show called Yo Gabba Gabba because
this is the type of propaganda that is
teaching
that is actually um
programming us
to not judge aliens, right? Because
they're just, you know, they're
friendly. They're just people like us,
right? Listen to this. Super Martian
Robot Girl.
Yeah!
A small town street on a normal-looking
day when suddenly Excuse me, miss. Do
you LIKE MY NEW HAIR OH. A monster!
Oh, no, you're judging the monster. So,
basically this monster uh keeps coming
out to different people and he's trying
to show off his haircut and everybody's
scared of him.
And then Super Martian Robot Girl
Martian
robot AI, it's literally alien alien AI
girl
that is the superhero for your kids.
And this is what she says.
[Music]
I think he just wants to ask us all a
question.
>> Yes, that's true. I just wanted to know
if you like my new haircut. OH!
MR. Monster might look different than
us, but that doesn't mean HE'S SCARY.
YEAH.
SO, WHAT DOES EVERYONE THINK OF MY new
hairstyle? Wow, that's actually
Can I get the number? My work here is
done.
Super Martian Robot Girl. And when you
look at the This is always the same.
Every time it ends,
she says up here, "My work here is done.
Goodbye, everyone." And yay! And all
these people are cheering, but what do
you see here? An alien and a demon.
And they're, you know, cheering
together. They're always friends. Every
one of these episodes that I've ever
seen is literally about the same thing.
There was another one where there was
like a shrimp monster and a
It's always some
alien creature
that is just trying to be friendly
and people are scared until Mar- Super
Martian Robot Girl comes along and she
says, "Oh, you shouldn't be scared.
They're just different." This is how
propaganda works. It's it's veiled in a
veneer of "Oh, it's teaching kids to
not,
you know, judge other people, make fun
of other people, or be scared of people
who are a little bit different." But
these are monsters. This isn't somebody
in a wheelchair or somebody disabled or
something like that or a different race.
They're monsters. They're aliens, right?
They're demons in disguise. This made me
think of the movie The Eternals. I've
never seen the movie, but I looked up a
synopsis with spoilers because I was
like, "I'm never going to watch this
movie. Give me the spoilers." Notice how
it says, "In the beginning." Where do we
hear that? In the Bible, right? What do
we see here? A UFO. I've seen the
previews, I've seen the trailer.
Um in the trailer, there's this UFO that
comes and it looks like it's appearing
to different cultures of the world,
maybe even different timelines because I
saw them in front of the walls of
Babylon, interestingly enough. And
they're the Eternals. They've been
around for thousands of years watching.
And And this is what the the monologue
is saying,
"We've been watching and we have never
interfered until now." And I was like, I
can I can just predict. This stuff is so
predictable. I was like, "I bet this
movie is about um
these aliens that come to humanity and,
you know, they've been watching, but
they never interfered until now because
there's a threat to the world and these
aliens are going to unite with humanity
to fight against this one threat,
right?" Because that's exactly what the
Bible says is going to happen when
demons
trick humanity into fighting against
Christ. And I read it and sure enough,
it's exactly what the movie is about.
And notice when this movie came out,
November.
Wait a minute. Aren't we being told that
aliens are going to come in November?
Look at the man, this like None of this
stuff is coincidence. All These people
are obsessed with numerology, with
predictive programming.
This is not an accident. And it brings
me to Reagan's speech. Because what did
he say? "We know we know that we're
looking for a new world order to happen,
right? A one world government, a one
world religion, the mark of the beast,
all these things um
What is it? The digital ID is coming.
You know what's so messed up about
digital ID? It connects one ID system to
everything you own, your car, your
phone, your electricity, all that stuff.
And when AI takes over most everyone's
jobs, this is what Elon said, we're
going to have to
change to some kind of new universal
credit system.
What is that system? That would be the
social credit system where you get
rewarded for being a good citizen
because we're going to make everyone
like robots. And if you
uh jaywalk, well, your credit score goes
down. You don't get to eat today.
But if you go to the universal church,
the one world church,
well, you you'll have enough points that
you can buy food for the whole week.
Just go to church, man. It's no big
deal. It's It's a great place. It's all
about coexistence and love and unity and
peace and safety. Just go. Just bow to
the image at the sound of the music.
It's It's no big deal, man. Shadrach,
Meshach, and Abednego, you guys are
zealots. You're You're extremist.
Just bow down, man. It's just a statue.
No big deal. Everyone's doing it.
This is what's coming, guys.
Digital IDs.
If you don't If you do something wrong,
um
maybe you did something immoral,
well, your electricity gets cut off.
Your car doesn't run because it's all
They're all Teslas now.
And so how are we going to get to this
new world order? How are we going to get
everyone to be a part of this one world
system? Well, Reagan had something
interesting to say at the United
Nations. In our obsession with
antagonisms of the moment,
we often forget how much unites all the
members of humanity.
Perhaps we need some outside universal
threat
to make us recognize this common bound.
I occasionally think how quickly our
differences worldwide would vanish if we
were facing an alien threat from outside
this world.
And yet I ask you,
is not an alien force already among us?
Yeah, it's called 3i Atlas.
Look, guys, the stage is being set. That
That
speech was like 1978 or something. I
can't remember the exact year, but look
it up. Reagan speech He said it over and
over.
He always talked about this how how our
differences would just go away if we
were threatened by some alien threat.
And you don't think Satan's going to use
that tactic?
Right? Carol Rosen was the mouthpiece
for Wernher von Braun, who was a Nazi
scientist who became a NASA scientist, a
rocket scientist.
And this is what she said that he was
telling her in his last days. And this
clip is
20 years old.
When I was a corporate manager of
Fairchild Industries in 1974 through
'77,
I met the late Dr. Wernher von Braun in
early '74.
Von Braun's purpose in life during the
last years of his life, his dying years,
was to educate the public and decision
makers about why space-based weapons are
dumb, dangerous, destabilizing, too
costly, unnecessary, unworkable,
undesirable idea.
The strategy that Wernher von Braun
taught me was that first the Russians
are going to be considered to be the
enemy. In fact, when I met him in '74,
they were the enemy, the identified
enemy. We were told that they had killer
satellites. We were told that they were
coming to get us and control us, the
dirty commies, that whole story. First
the Russians were the enemy against whom
we're going to build space-based
weapons. Then terrorists would be
identified, and that was soon to follow.
We heard a lot about terrorism.
Then we were going to identify third
world country crazies. We now call them
nations of concern. But he said that
would be the third enemy against whom we
would be needing to build space-based
weapons.
And the next enemy was asteroids. Now,
at this point, he kind of chuckled the
first time he said it.
Asteroids against asteroids we're going
to build space-based weapons. So, it was
funny then.
And the funniest one of all was against
what he called aliens,
extraterrestrials. That would be the
final card.
And over and over and over during the
four years that I knew him and was
giving his speeches for him,
he would bring up that last card and
remember, Carol, the last card is the
alien card. We're going to have to build
space-based weapons against aliens, and
all of it, he said, is a lie.
So, the stage is being set, guys.
Like
he knew something in his last days,
Wernher von Braun.
And he was warning He He was starting to
have a guilty conscience about
what he was a part of.
And he was telling her, "Look, these
space-based weapons,
laser beams, directed energy weapons,
ooh, you're crazy Jewish Jewish laser
beams, you're conspiracy theorist,
anti-Semitic racist." That's what they
accuse you of if you believe
in the truth of directed energy weapons.
We literally looked at the declassified
documents about them.
But they label you a conspiracy
theorist, anti-Semitic, all these
things, right?
She said
that Wernher von Braun was saying,
"They're going to be telling you about
terrorists. They're going to be telling
you about asteroids and comets.
And then it's going to be the alien
card, the final card."
We're being told that this month aliens
are coming, and conveniently the
government shut down, and NASA won't
release the photos, and so they're
pushing this whole thing that NASA's
hiding the truth, and we need to know.
This is what they want.
This is what they want. They want you to
believe that the power is in your hands
to get the truth out there.
And I fell for it.
I think this is a a very interesting
tombstone that Wernher von Braun has
because he has a Bible verse on there.
This is on PBS This is on Nova
PBS website.
And it says Psalm 19:1.
Does anybody know what's so interesting
about Psalm 19:1?
I'm I'm assuming he put this on his own
tombstone. Like he
requested that this be put on his
tombstone.
Psalm 19:1 says, "The heavens declare
the glory of God, and the firmament
showeth his handiwork."
Now, this might be completely new to
some of you,
but I believe the Bible.
And when you read Genesis, you'll see
that during creation
the whole world was nothing but water
until God put a firmament
in the midst of the water that divided
the waters below from the waters above.
Now, some people say, "Oh, that's
That was the clouds, the clouds that
hold water. They're waters above or the
atmosphere."
Well, then you have a really big problem
because right after that it says that
God put the sun, moon, and stars in the
firmament. That would be in the
atmosphere or in the clouds.
So, according to what we've been taught
our whole life, indoctrination in camps
that we grew up in, we were told that
we're on this spinning rock in a
ever-expanding universe, and
everything's twisting and turning,
but that's not what we see.
You look at time-lapse
pictures of the stars. You point it at
the North Star, and it makes perfect
circles, not some spirograph.
When uh
there's so many things that prove that
there literally is a firmament over our
head that divides the waters above from
the waters below. Stars literally look
like LED lights underwater.
Now, I'm saying this, it might be
completely crazy to you. You might not
even believe it, but I believe the
Bible.
And I believe that science backs
up what the Bible says. Over and over,
the Bible talks about the firmament, and
in the Hebrew it says that it's a a
solid structure that was beaten out with
a
magical
ozone layer or atmosphere that you can
fly up enough until you go pop out into
outer space where there's
weightlessness.
The reason I'm bringing this up is
because it's the truth.
It's the truth of the word of God, and
when you understand where we live in
God's creation, you will know that there
are no such thing as
asteroids and comets and aliens coming
to Earth.
This is literally a demonic deception.
If you don't understand that by now, I
pray that this
has opened your mind some. Please go to
our channel,
scroll through our lives, and and I give
a whole presentation on proving that
aliens are demons in disguise. They're
spiritual beings. They defy the laws of
physics. They walk through walls. They
enter into people. People channel them.
People
uh summon them through New Age
meditation.
You don't have some visitant from a
galaxy millions of light-years away just
show up because somebody's meditating in
a field. It makes no sense. All of this
is a spiritual deception, and we know
that Satan is going to deceive the
entire world.
That's what is soon to come.
Guys, we are living in the last days. I
hope that is clear to you. We see that
they are miracle-working demons going
forth to the kings of the Earth,
rounding them up to fight against
Christ. We have a space force literally
with weapons pointed towards the
heavens, getting ready for this battle.
We're being told by the military that
at US Congressional hearings that we
communicate with non-human intelligences
and we know that the Bible says that all
these false gods and anything that
you're talking to that isn't human is a
demon in disguise.
The military is telling us we
communicate with demons and soon we are
going to be uniting with them in a
battle against Christ because the Bible
prophecy says it is true.
If you like this video, please give a
thumbs up. If you disliked it, please
give it a thumbs down. Any interaction
with this video helps it get into the
algorithm. This truth needs to be told.
This truth needs to be heard and we live
in 2025, man. It's time to wake up and
start listening to other people's
perspectives and stop mocking and
ridiculing somebody because
they believe something differently than
you. Keep an open mind. Listen to all
sides. That's how I got to where I'm at
today because I I've always been a truth
seeker. I've always wanted to know the
truth even if it goes against everything
I've ever thought to be true, I want to
know truth.
And right now there's controlled
propaganda that's saying if you believe
that aliens are demons
you're some archaic caveman and you're a
bigot and you need to get out of here.
You need to be locked up in a loony bin,
but
let's keep listening to this Harvard
scientist professor because he has a lab
coat and a degree
and he says that it's aliens coming.
So, we're about to face something really
crazy. I hope you guys are ready. I hope
I'm ready. I hope this was eye-opening
to you. Please share this with your
family and friends. If you're new to
this channel, click subscribe, click the
notification bell so you don't miss
another show that we do. If you want to
support this ministry, we are completely
100% donation based besides when we go
speak places. If you want to support
this ministry, invite us to your church,
invite us to your school, invite us to
your event. You can also give through
Cash App, Venmo, Zelle, and PayPal. It's
the end of the year. People are looking
for ministries to give to
um for that tax-deductible gift. Please
consider giving to us. Um if you like
t-shirts, we got a lot of cool t-shirts
on our website candidtruth.org.
Check those out and we get about $5 on
everything that sells on there. We love
you guys. We cannot do this without you
guys. If you have been a faithful giver,
we see you and we thank you and we
cannot thank you enough. It's all thanks
to you that we can even do this and we
will see you next time on Candid Truth.